[Music]
so a really major thing I think for lots
of disabled artists is that we are still
relatively unexpected in the art space
we're not necessarily expected on stages
we're still not necessarily represented
on our TV screens but the reality is
that if you are a person who has a
visible difference of whatever it might
be you're always performing and whether
people are bought a ticket or not and
for me being still a relatively new CEO
of an arts and disability organization
in Australia I am NOT the image that
gets conjured up when people think of
what a CEO is or who they are and I'm
really interested this week for us to
challenge I suppose the status quo in
terms of putting our bodies our diverse
bodies in spaces where we might not be
expected
people with disabilities are somehow
always different that we can never
switch off
we are always some whatever wherever we
are we are changing something in in the
world when whatever we are doing
actually because we are constantly
changing people's view on how they see
people with disabilities can you even
wash your car or can you can you dance
I mean it's these quite silly questions
that people can ask you I like to show
the body
I feel like persons with disability not
often very often show their body in life
in advertising's in TV in everywhere
they just show in the doctor appointment
or something like that so on stage I
like to show what we are and uniqueness
of that and it's quite interesting to
see that we are not all the same we are
not all copies of the same thing so I
used this idea of shop and
this idea of political states of the
bodies to question the identity our
office has human beings there's several
things we've been asking the artists
this week specifically in relationship
to site specific and site responsive
work we've been asking them to think
about the memory of a place that in any
site that we come to that there's
something that's been here already
so what's been here before and how does
that inform our response to it what
meanings come associated with a space
we've been asking them to think about
the choreography that already exists in
a place so the patterns of movement how
people inhabits and move through a space
and for them as artists whether it's the
space that's been designed with them in
mind or not and so how they might resist
the choreography that exists already
within that space or echo or amplify
that choreography we've also been asking
to think about consent and control both
in terms of site-specific work with
audience but also as performers when
we're seen and when we see so we've been
placing that question of what you want
to invite and how do you navigate
permission
[Music]
problems of the trouble
Maria Maria jawoll knows artistic
nabuwah jobina post-reagan options
nipple knows provenance
allergy is a Prezy a normal engine or
motive not a leathersmith Chaplin tangos
approach each this bar so true not of
oat porridge in each album Roberto
Benigni vadhana a letters in each album
reputable hipper Donna cherubims Robert
and Fiat Toronto a buddhist temple la
artists to snip honest promise Jami
rubbish Managua not a miserable
immigrant in Surabaya is reach the goal
is rubber is rubbish Managua
preservative to attract arabic arabic to
care
neroon nice artist a me sushi APPA a
normative mega should bestow to the
patrol just to catch a bit of elastic
inclusive now
[Music]
we were particularly interested in
hosting this kind of lab in thinking
about how different bodies and different
identities interact with their kind of
urban environment here in Malmo for
example going that direction there is a
skate park there was somebody who said
when we were there the other day that
it's amazing to see how different wheels
interact in that kind of urban landscape
so we wanted just to have a week for
artists to explore different than Lima
in the city
[Music]
the rules change when you doing
site-specific performance so when we're
in a theater and people are buying a
ticket there's specific rules that are
established there's the things we grow
up knowing you do in a theater about you
sit in the dark and be quiet and watch
whereas in site-specific work that
doesn't happen the audience can come and
go as they please people can just come
through a performance space potentially
so it's a very different negotiation
that goes on outdoors then happens in
traditional theater spaces
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you